melissa is in Lancaster Pennsylvania hi
Melissa welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi thank you for honoring me with your
time today I appreciate it my pleasure
how can I help so I'm selling my house
and I stand to make about $40,000 on it
after I sell it I have a car loan that's
about $9,000 that I plan to pay off I
throw that I'm completely debt-free but
I also don't have any retirement and so
I'm just trying to determine is it
better for me to take the $31,000 that I
have left over and kind of put that back
into purchasing another house or should
I put that into savings retirement or
what would you suggest
okay what's your income about 42,000
here okay and what's the price range of
home you shold
the house that I'm selling is about 280
Wow yeah and I'm only looking to buy one
that's around 165 okay
you weren't servicing 280 on 40 mm I
work together and we have separated and
so I'm going from a double income
payment long ago okay and that's what I
was guessing okay sorry about that
yeah you have children I have a 20 year
old daughter who's in college okay all
right so you have children that you have
to worry about for housing okay
well the first thing is that yes I you
don't you you did do the right thing by
paying off the car out of this in your
mind and following through on that and
yes I would set aside three to six
months of expenses as an emergency fund
I would cheat down to the three side in
this situation giving you as much of a
down payment as you can possibly have on
the next house and that house should be
where the payments are no more than 1/4
of your take-home pay on a 15-year fixed
I don't think that's putting you into a
165 okay I think that's going to bring
you down further than that which could
mean that you may how long were you
married well in 20 years come on later
30 25
how long was I married yeah probably 25
years oh no no it was a second marriage
so we were only married for eight years
okay all right
I was just thinking it's okay to set
okay pay off the car set aside an
emergency fund set the other portion
aside on a separate account call that
your house fund rent something
inexpensive and whatever emotional
recovery you might need give yourself
six months and then make a decision on
buying a house the only problem with
that is it entails a couple of moves
rather than one move right and I was
kind of concerned because my rent around
this area is more than what my mortgage
could potentially be but it would be a
30-year fix only 10% down and that's why
I was kind of going back and forth yeah
I'm always going to put you down because
the thing is it's it's an okay thing in
your situation to do the 30 that on the
short term that feels like the right
thing did I get back into homeownership
you know I got my future lined out and
those kinds of things what let me ask
you this what's the path on your career
look like I mean are you looking to see
your income come up substantially in the
next few years
no okay all right so you you the 30-year
mortgage is not a good long-term play
okay and because it just traps you and
it ends up not being the best thing for
you long term so I'm gonna move on down
in house or I'm gonna tap the brakes and
wait and rent is always higher in every
area by the way that's not different
there are it's always higher than
payments but payments but owning a home
is always more expensive in annually
than than renting but it is not more
expensive over the long haul because it
goes up in value but you've got repairs
and you've got all kinds of issues and
other things you have to deal with when
you're the homeowner anything that
breaks you got to fix it
you're a tenant the landlord gets to fix
all that and so this is one of the
reasons that rents are a little higher
so it's a temporary measure
even though rents are higher might be
okay to kind of get stabilized and start
thinking about your long-term career
prospects and plans given this life
change that you've gone through and then
that might change what you purchase or
where you purchase even and so there's
just a lot of upheaval and a lot of
change and a lot of pain in your life
and those are never good times to make
great decisions so you sound really
stable and upbeat and everything on the
air so maybe I'm overstating this maybe
I'm adding melodrama to it I don't know
but those are always just concerns with
what you're going through and I want you
to just be careful and be steady careful
instead he always wins you know so take
your time
but yeah pay off the car and set aside
an emergency phone work with work with
what's left and then if you're going to
do something today I would do a 15-year
fixed and I would do it where the
payments no more than 1/4 of your
take-home pay thanks for the call